in the heart of the sea is directed by
Ron Howard and stars Chris Hemsworth and
is the story of Moby Dick a giant whale
that took on a bunch of whalers back in
the day in the story of survival that
ensued after an attack on their ship
before I get into the meat of my video I
want to make sure that you guys know to
stay tuned for the end of this because
I'm excited to tell you guys about a new
sponsorship that I'm running with and
that is loot crate they're doing
something very cool in December Star
Wars related I'm going to talk to you
guys about that at the end of the video
ever since I saw jaws for the first time
as a kid I was always enticed by the
seat there was something about it that
was startling to me something about it
that creeped me out
it gave me the chills there are times
where the camera Bob's underwater and
you're greeted with the sight of five to
ten whales and you realize that you are
just a speck you're a little tiny piece
of nothing and that's my favorite aspect
of this movie there is a theme going
throughout it that men can't really do a
thing against nature that were just
little bits of dust and if nature
decides to look poorly on us one day
well we're screwed and similar to a
recent Ron Howard film also starring
Chris Hemsworth called Rush this film is
also about two men who are competing
with one another we have Chris Hemsworth
who wants to be a captain and then we
have a guy who actually is the captain
because of his family name Hemsworth's
character has earned this position but
this guy got it because of his family
name and so they're automatically at
odds with one another and those two
parts of the film man against nature and
man against man are my favorite parts of
in the heart of the sea the unfortunate
truth behind this movie for me was I
really didn't give a crap about any of
these characters the movie takes a long
time to get interesting it's not until
the third act that I actually started
caring and if you don't really care that
much about the characters until the
third act well that can get pretty
boring even though all the trailers are
trying to make you think this movie is
actually about a giant whale it's not
that thing is hardly in the movie it
shows up every once in a while to maybe
some a kabocha and have the boat go
flying and oh crap but the movie itself
is really just about the two men on the
ship and their confrontation with one
another and that aspect of the movie I
liked it's just that it also is trying
to be this epic sea adventure and the
way the film is shot the cinematography
is extremely
you just don't feel that epic scope when
you watch this movie because a lot of it
really does appear as if it was shot on
a green screen background the CGI for
the whales I thought was terrific
and even though I didn't really feel
their presence and especially Moby
Dick's I certainly didn't feel that he
was this terrifying thing to be reckoned
with they were at least really
good-looking and they looked realistic
and I bought into them being there but I
never really felt the grace or the
majesty of these creatures they were
just there to make everyone else have a
shitty day which was disappointing
because whales are some of the most
beautiful creatures on earth and I never
really got the sense that they were
these things that we were supposed to be
fearful of and that if they decided we
don't like you one day that could be
really bad for anyone in a boat and yes
the film depicts those events as
terrifying and very frightening but you
just don't feel the epic scope of Moby
Dick
it just it's not there it feels a little
bit low-key think about in 1975 s jaws
the first time you really see that shark
you feel it and that was with a
mechanical shark in the 70s this film
with all of its technological advances I
just didn't feel the weight of this
creature I didn't feel the impact of
this creature because a lot of this
movie does look very artificial Chris
Hemsworth and the rest of the cast
really dedicated themselves to their
roles losing a lot of weight it's very
impressive and their performances are
mostly good although Hemsworth and his
accent does go off and on quite often
overall I would say the acting in the
movie was fine I wanted it to feel like
there were more stakes I wanted there to
be more weight to the drama even when
our heroes are trying hard to survive
and they don't have much food you just
don't really care that much because I
personally didn't care for the
characters even our main hero was just
given the screenwriting basics a wife at
home who's pregnant that doesn't mean we
automatically like the guy I just I
didn't really care that much for the
characters and I just didn't feel that
epic weight and scope this movie needed
that being said I liked the man against
nature element and I liked the man
against man element of our first mate
and Captain at odds with one another
those are the best parts of in the heart
of the sea as a film I was disappointed
by it
overall I'm going to give in the heart
of the sea a c+ if you do see the film
maybe check it out on a matinee price it
is worth watching it's just
disappointing for what it could have
been and who was behind the camera so
like I said at the beginning of this
video I really want to thank lootcrate
for sponsoring this video their December
crate is Star Wars Episode 7 force
awakens which oh my gosh I can't wait to
see Galaxy Quest halo 5 it's a geek box
of Awesomeness that can be sent to you
once a month filled with amazing things
and I left a link in the description
below so you can get a discount on this
if you go to loot crate comm slash Chris
Stockman and use the coupon code Chris
when you check out you can get 10% off
of your loot crate subscription and you
can do that up until December 19th 9
p.m. Pacific Time December's crate will
have 5 exclusive items you can't get
anywhere else including a t-shirt and a
Funko pop that you cannot get anywhere
except loot crate and starting in
December they're going to have an
exclusive t-shirt and every single crate
that's awesome I love these guys because
I'm a nerd and you know geek stuff thank
you very much for watching guys
you're the best if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes